on est sur la défense des amendements
maintenant allez-y madame kéké vous avez
la parole
excusez-moi
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente
de Président je vous prie de m'excuser
allez-y tous les noirs ne se ressemblent
pas
elle a dit qu'elle est 13h d'assembler
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez Géraldine
circuler il y a rien à voir il y a
absolument pas de problème comme on
Valérie me le disait tout à l'heure elle
avait confondu déjà des deux députés
blancs donc voilà absolument pas de
problème ça fait 13h qu'elle est là ils
sont fatigués tout va bien après
Nadège à beaumont-goli
je suis sûr qu'il est pas d'accord
quand on parle de c'est pas le match
tout à l'heure bien sûr je me prends des
sauts des sauts de trucs en me disant de
leurs dans TPMP people qui traite jamais
de Palmade et qui défend les petits
copains homosexuels non c'est parce que
Balma c'est traité ici c'est des sujets
traités ici nous c'est plus léger si
j'ai rien compris ton émission en fait
non mais tu nous en parlera tout à
l'heure ça te dérange pas du tout mais
donc là il y a pas de racisme voilà
Gilles c'est du racisme ordinaire tout
ça c'est-à-dire que en filigrane c'est
tous les noirs se ressemblent
alors pourquoi quand tu consens des deux
députés blancs c'est pas un problème et
quand tu confonds deux députés noirs
j'ai dit que là il y avait un problème
c'est-à-dire que contre les Blancs aussi
alors j'ai dit que là il y avait un
problème d'ailleurs les les deux femmes
le ressenti comme tel et le tous les
noirs ne se ressemblent pas c'est sorti
du cœur elle doit aller en prison c'est
quoi en fait la sanction dans ces cas-là
mais Géraldine ne me sautez pas dessus
comme ça j'ai même pas et qui te dit que
pour les Asiatiques
qu'est-ce que tu en sais je dis que
c'est du racisme ordinaire qui fait mal
au noir parce que c'est en filigrane
tous les noirs se ressemblent je suis
désolé vous ne le ressentez pas comme ça
mais certains salariés étaient noires à
l'intérieur tu sais tout ça nana c'est
n'importe quoi ce que tu dis c'est
n'importe quoi mais donc ça veut dire
qu'on a pas le droit de dire de deux
personnes noires qu'elle se ressemblent
selon toi c'est ça sinon c'est raciste
non mais j'ai pas dit ça elle confond
deux personnes deux députés en tant que
présidente de la journée moi
Daniel avec Valérie ou Daniel avec
Jean-Marie
non mais c'est fou d'avoir un malaise
autour de ça qui est raciste depuis un
malaise autour de ça
tout le monde se marre effectivement la
député fait une petite remarque les gens
trouvent ça léger et parce qu'il y a
trois mecs sur Twitter qui ont trouvé ça
exactement elle est taxé immédiatement
c'est scandaleux c'est immédiatement
excusée
on peut reprocher qu'elle connaît pas
les gens à qui est boss oui ça c'est
quand même grave de pas savoir avec qui
tu travailles et son excuse ça fait 13h
je suis à l'Assemblée pour faire
travailler les gens deux ans de plus en
plus
il y a 300 personnes
là c'est quand même en direct oui elle a
des heures de taf derrière elle toi en
direct on a dit aussi des conneries on
était pas tomber dessus
moi je dis pas que je dis pas que c'est
raciste
je dis juste que renseigne-toi et qui tu
travailles même la dame qui fait la
réflexion je sais pas si elle est aussi
énervée qu'on le pense pas tu vois
la France insoumise des
instrumentalisent le truc parce qu'ils
font
de la connaissez avant
elle fait la même réflexion avec les
deux députés deux dépendant ici on en
parle pas et ça fait aucune polémique
elle ne connaît pas plus que les que les
deux là c'est ça qui est qui est
dérangeant pourquoi tu fais le polémique
quand ces deux personnes de couleur et
pourquoi il y a pas de polémique quand
c'est les deux si vous voulez
c'est quoi le truc mais bien sûr
une mauvaise question mais c'est pas
tout à fait pareil quand ce sont des
noirs et quand ce sont des blancs ma
chère quoi
non mais c'est une question intéressante
mais je m'embourbe pas du tout
excusez-moi le racisme anti-blanc n'est
pas du tout proportionné au racisme en
chinois il y a pas eu l'esclavage des
noirs etc donc c'est pas la même chose
que tu dises que c'est la même chose je
respecte ton avis
et votre avis est important pour moi et
les autres non bah si bien sûr mais
Kelly particulièrement rien à
pour moi ton avis